fin a la tregua las explosiones
nocturnas volvieron a iluminar los
cielos en la franja de gaza tras un
ataque del ejército israelí que asegura
respondía a hostilidades del grupo
islamista hamás
activamos una unidad nocturna para
apoyar a nuestra gente en jerusalén
y nos molestaremos en respuesta a la
marcha de las banderas
horas antes del ataque aéreo cientos de
ultranacionalistas israelíes salieron a
las calles de jerusalén esté despertando
la ira de los palestinos
no vinimos aquí para decirle a hamás que
el estado de israel es el señor de la
tierra de jerusalén no sucumbiremos
asustados ni a sus amenazas
los lanzamientos ponen a prueba la paz
en la región acordada tras 11 días de
intercambios bélicos que dejaron 225
muertos en gaza y 13 en israel con la
mediación de egipto y las presiones de
varios gobiernos entre ellos el de joe
biden así como la respuesta que dará el
nuevo gobierno de nafta live net el
conflicto se había reanudado el 10 de
mayo tras días de enfrentamientos entre
manifestantes palestinos y la policía de
israel cerca de la mezquita al-aqsa un
lugar sagrado para judíos y musulmanes
jamás disparó cohetes hacia jerusalén
israel respondió según la onu unos 58
mil palestinos han huido de sus hogares
desde entonces refugiándose en escuelas
de naciones unidas'